what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation I am going to do a first
time watching for the Disney animated
film Princess and the Frog I don't even
know if I've seen a trailer for this
movie
wow that's rare anyway guys uh this is
the last movie I am shooting a reaction
for the put up for a while I'm out of
town getting hitched and of course Coy
and John will be there it'd be weird if
they weren't they're more important than
the misses so that's such a dog if she's
watching don't know that's not a joke
anyway we're gonna be uh watching this
leave a like that would mean the world I
love that if you could do it I'm just
loading this on Disney plus and if you
want to do a full interaction watch
along with me on whatever copy you can
get your hands out of the full Thrasher
watches logs are available for super
sexual rejects that are patreon and we
cover a bunch of stuff over there as
well exclusively with reaction
highlights and watch along is included
and we are good to go let's see what
this movie is all about
[Music]
was this the I think the thing I heard
was this is the last hand-drawn animated
movie from Disney and they said this
doesn't make enough money oh please dear
princess only a kiss from you can break
this terrible spell that was inflicted
on me by a wicked witch classic the
beautiful princess picked up the
slippery creature
leaned forward
raised him to her lips
kiss that little frog
I know it's a frog it's kind of gross
it's transformed into a handsome prince
they were married and lived happily ever
after
yeah gotta go knocking on some frogs
do you ever I mean never kiss a frog
you are being abusive to the cat
[Music]
I will do it
kids are from
these little white girl's crazy
[Music]
adorable
you could whip something up like that is
that John Goodman's voice
hmm
this is the best combo I've ever tasted
come here
oh but look at the communal experience
about good food it brings folks together
from all walks of life ain't that the
truth and when I opened up my home
restaurant I tell you people are gonna
line up for miles around just to get a
taste of my food our food
our food
Tiana's place
you make a wish on the evening star
that old star can only take you parted
away
you gotta help along with some hard work
of your own and the law of action
thought feeling action just promise your
daddy one thing
that you'll never ever lose sight of
what's really important
okay
money
you focus on money
[Music]
I do miss good old-fashioned hand-drawn
animation well miss Tiana rough night
for tips but
don't you worry Daddy
we'll be there soon
oh that's
that's sad it's touching
I'm enjoying these Tunes
[Music]
New Orleans still like this
[Music]
wow they got a real magic oh my God
[Music]
well hello handsome
dreams do come true
[Music]
wow not interested at all
at least marry him for his money
we're all going out dancing tonight
besides you need napkins sweetheart
if I do a winning the Kentucky
I was totally making a joke about her
focusing on making money I didn't think
the movie would actually be about is
that about it
invited the prince to a masquerade
and
he's staying in our house is my personal
guess wow that's a big deal my mama
always said the quickest way to a man's
heart is through his stomach
amen sister I'ma need about 500 of your
man kitchen Beignets for my ball tonight
this might cover it this should cover it
just fine
I'm getting my restaurant
the odds
look at it Mama doesn't it just make you
Wanna Cry
and some yeah
that's all I want for you sweetheart to
meet your prince charming and dance off
and do your happily ever after huh I
don't have time for dancing
just gonna have to wait a while but
you've got time for singing
I know exactly where I'm going I'm
getting closer and closer every day wow
[Music]
whoa cool
[Music]
nah man you're almost there get your
goals done
overcome those obstacles
[Music]
that's right you persevere
this this is delightful
[Music]
I love this animation
[Music]
you are kind of losing side of
relationships and connections as you're
growing up
[Music]
oh I was there this is why catchy ass
song damn Tiana girls actually is a very
relatable plotline we've all wanted to
open our own restaurant right I buy
everyone here a drink you have two
choices
for reals
gentlemen or something
how y'all doing
oh my God whose voice is that I have a
wager I'm in the company I have a
visiting royalty it's pretty obvious
it's remarkable gentleman has just read
my poem this chap is obviously a
charlatan you're in my world now not
your world
I got friends on the other side the
other side of what
that's a nickel gentlemen just a little
something we have here in Louisiana a
little politics
[Music]
if you relax it will enable me to do
without anything at least
God this music's amazing the cards will
tell the past the present and the future
as well just take three
take a little trip into your future with
me what's the harm in just taking a look
you come from two long lives
I'm a royal myself or my mother
it's the greenest the green is the green
you need and when I looked into your
future it's the green that I see
I
see
your future the you I see is exactly the
man you always wanted to be the one in
charge
oh my God
what is going on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's some cool Voodoo [ __ ] oh is he
like is he turning him into a frog and
they're doing like a reversal thingy
just an educated guess based off the
fact they haven't brought the Frog
around it's getting be so late there's
still a few straggles
please please please you can't just wish
on a star and expect things
[Music]
did not turn into a frog
[Music]
wow look at that classic Disney gonna be
the house you'll see once I sign those
papers y'all Brock yes about that oh
what did you next do
what by who came in offered the full
amount in cash oh my God little woman of
your background would have had a hands
full trying to run a big business like
oh man now hold on there you come come
back
oh that's painful what happened
rich white family isn't racist I was
starting to think that Wishing on Stars
was just for babies and crazy people
oh aren't you justice pretty as a
magnolia in May back into The Fray
good luck oh poor Tiana that's a real
bummer
believe I'm doing this
you gotta put it in action but pushing
to the universe never bad thing I reckon
you want a kiss
ing would be nice yeah wow
have a very strong iron princess oh he
did get turned into a frog it's him I am
Prince Naveen
must kiss me if excuse me you will enjoy
I guarantee all women enjoy the keys of
Prince Naveen come we pack her
oh God
no no
surely I could offer you some type of
reward a wish I could Grant perhaps oh
don't just no
just
one kiss the kiss has to go to true love
and let you beg for more oh God
you're one disgusting perverted frog
oh what happened but how'd you get way
up there and how did I get way down here
and all this oh oh my God
[Music]
that is not slime what you are secreting
mucus oh Tiana
[Music]
just talked to me yeah yeah what I can't
get through with this
[Music]
why would you want to look that way you
wear this this Costless thing
anything happens to this I'm gonna be
fun fact about Voodoo Larry
can't conjure a thing for myself oh
interesting is that true is that part of
the rules all you got to do is marry Big
Daddy's Little Princess and we will be
splitting that juicy Libra Fortune right
down ah
I'm not a princess I'm a waitress you
weren't wearing a crown it was a costume
party you spoiled little rich boy oh yes
well the egg is on your face all right
because I do not have any riches oh my
God literally broke
never heard anyone say it was such Pride
I want you two are married you are gonna
keep your promise and get me my rest I
made that promise to a beautiful
princess not the cranky wit why are
those logs moving
those aren't locks wow
they're all gonna fight for these two
frogs
help me get out of this ah they go right
back to moving slow and hunt
you can hop
looks like we're going to be here for a
while
we may as well get
confidence sleaze back
God damn it I got a little less Piggy
play it brother
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Mama Odie she the voodoo queen of the
Bayou she got magic and spells all kind
of who do that would actually come in
handyman
[Music]
so hot and strong like no one they've
ever seen parts of this cat arriving
here Jungle Book
[Music]
she's an independent hard-working girl
it's funny how us humans are so bad at
achieving what these reptiles want to
achieve you had to endure that
I'll be asked
when you're next in line for the throne
you're poised like a panther ready to
expect
[Laughter]
your ear
I can no longer ignore the throbbing of
my
yikes
it got me blushes
becoming princess of meldonia
are you serious
that's the plague
what do we do now I'm reduced to asking
for Help from My Friends on the other
side
what oh no there is no way I'm kissing a
frog and eating a bug on the same day I
mean you got turned into a frog You
Gotta Throw That Into The Mix
oh oh oh
you don't find anything to eat yeah oh
my I know miles that's raunchy
let me tell you something girl I guess
you and your boyfriend gonna look good I
love all the Louisiana personalities are
infused into all the animal characters
guts from the stomach Mama Woody y'all
had the wrong direction
[Music]
around
stick I was confused by the topography
and the the geography and the
choreography and first rule to buy you
never take direction from a gator
oh wow
[Music]
this movie is cute
I Love Actually as a walker seems our
little froggy prince lost his way and I
need your generous assistance getting
them back
I hear you dude these souls are going to
consume me by the end of the movie
I do love the horror elements of the
drawings because it does remind me of
like classic Disney
that's Supernatural peril
I can taste him frog legs already
[Music]
oh they should be able to hear them no
wait no
that's it
what
get that little one over there
ouch
[Music]
[Music]
dude this this guy's gonna have a
concussion watch this
[Music]
oh these are some clever ass frogs
they're even using dance in a way these
two ain't like no frogs I ever seen and
we talked too
[Applause]
I'm a little confused now that they're
frogs they can hear all the other
animals but none of these other like
bugs and alligators like humans can't
hear them right I'll start with a
pre-dinner cocktail and something to
nibble on but I wait you are gonna mince
these mushrooms do do what you're gonna
learn to do some labor with your hands
you spoiled frog
what
there you go when you live in a castle
everything is done for you dress you
they feed you drive you brush your teeth
wipe your butt
[Music]
spooky it's like a Leica movie
[Music]
it's the star look how she lights up the
sky
she
[Music]
could love someone like me oh no I I
don't dance
frog you will dance
away I've never danced never all this
time in my life
is wonderful
Love is Everything
oh that's delightful
[Music]
damn
we best be pushing all
right oh she she wanted to kiss her if
she wanted it I feel like she's learning
looks don't matter
[Music]
not bad for a 197 year old Blind Lady oh
I'm going to love her
come on over here you bad boy
get a little sugar now
oh
no we don't want to take up too much of
your time I want some candy no no thank
you and now that's too bad it's a
special candy what a twin y'all human oh
we need to be human
y'all ain't got to say she was born with
y'all want to be human but you're blind
to what you need what we want what we
need is all the same thing yeah no no
not at all
don't matter what you look like don't
matter what you wear come in the rain
you got on your finger we don't care no
we don't oh this is gonna be a good one
I like this already
[Music]
oh it's a good song
[Music]
that's not what you need
[Music]
can often feel that way the ironic part
is it costs a lot of money to put this
movie together
[Music]
oh he knows what he wants he needs love
[Music]
oh this this one is a good number this
one on the um almost there fantastic
I need to dig a little deeper and work
even harder to get my restaurant
no that's not it
princess
but only till midnight you only got till
then to get that prices to kiss you
what she does
I think you guys just gotta kiss each
other
[Music]
no they're just instruments
oh
that is one killer dealer costume hey
Gator can you blow that horn
oh this is the perfect party boat I just
looked Tiana in the eye and say
and we'll do whatever it takes to make
all your dreams come true because
I love you whoa I'm in love with Tiana
knew it I knew it I knew it'd be so
happy I would find another way to get
the other restaurant
the job practically
guys no no you are not a guy let me
begin again oh you are a bumbling fool
when you're in love
Tiana
there it is your restaurant oh can't you
just picture you know a good ukulele
player really you let me perform I'll
talk to the owner owner says yes
with your help
our dream is finally coming true
oh damn it was gonna end what do I do
God damn it
Lawrence oh no hold still your eminence
have you seen Naveen look at you where
the ring at oh no don't give it away
because oh wait you're up tired of the
drum you ain't getting nothing out of me
no Ray okay Charlotte he go marry you as
soon as he get himself kisses
oh I just light it up and here I thought
no no
no you're misunderstanding this whole
situation just because you wish for
something doesn't make it true
my vageline always said to me if
Angeline's nothing but
just open your eyes now don't revert
back to who you were at the beginning of
the movie
are the power of this
I Now Pronounce You whoa
what's he doing I got it you got me too
it's interesting like the main villain
is his embodiment of what greed can do
to you
the pursuit of money
how can corrupt your soul again I'm
moving made by the richest company in
the world but I couldn't good message
what is this
shadow man get this no matter what no
wrong girl don't make me light my butt
you light your ass Ray
[Music]
know me come here
[Music]
did they really just squish him to death
oh I'm gonna break this thing into a
million pieces
oh my goodness
oh the ultimate Temptation that was one
hard-working man shame all that hard
work didn't amount to much more than a
busted up old Gumbo Pot and a dream that
never got off the back porch but he
always understood What mattered most
you can give your poor daddy
everything he ever wanted no no no he
already had everything he wanted
that's why he worked so hard
my daddy never did get what he wanted
but he had what he needed
but he had what he needed yeah girl he
never lost sign what was
and neither will I
[Music]
getting what you want versus what you
need
I like that I like that theme a lot it's
not slime it's mucus
[Music]
with your soul
[Music]
you had a car he had it coming
oh Hello darling
to introduce myself
I am the real Prince Naveen
if I kissed you before midnight you and
Tiana turn human again yeah more or less
but remember you must give Tian all the
money she requires for her restaurant
she is my Evangeline
don't do this I have to do this and we
are running out of time I won't let you
it's the only way to get to your dream
my dream
my dream wouldn't be complete
what are you in it
that's sweet too
oh do you
I read about true love and fairy tales
and you found it
I'll kiss him
no marriage required
[Music]
oh
I'm so sorry
I wish you wiped off all the lipstick
shadow man to lay Paul Ray low hey he's
hurting awful bad
oh poor Ray how'd he survive that how
come
yo
and we're staying together
we're staying frogs right I locked down
very much
Evangeline are you managers in his eyes
[Music]
oh really this is so unexpected poor Ray
foreign
gets to be with Evangeline though
[Music]
yay he gets to be with Evangeline
but now she'll frog
[Music]
frog
it's my good looking couple like I told
y'all he's an apprentice
that made you a princess it makes a lot
of sense it's real logical that's
extremely logical conclusion
[Music]
this is an inspiring independent woman
they should create a Tiana's Palace
would have had a younger brother
how old did you say you were I'm six and
a half
just wait a few years
[Music]
did they ever create like a Tiana's
Palace somewhere I'm going to New
Orleans baby
that was really cute
really really cute oh all righty another
Disney animated movie crossed off the
good old Greg list here and uh I enjoyed
it I thought it was a really cute
light-hearted Disney Flair I mean one of
the best parts about it is the fact that
it's hand-drawn animation you know just
there's a certain kind of movement and
uh that's pastel
elasticity to the the movement and the
expressions and body movement that you
don't quite get I mean sometimes the the
computer animation in some of these
movies is phenomenal they're gonna be
Rochester with the human movements
they've they've certainly
um vastly evolved since like this movie
came out I think in 2009 and since then
if we've gotten like so much more
mind-blowing like I just watched Moana
recently that was like mind-blowing and
I I really think that you know that's
part of the the touch that I missed was
that was that was that frame to frame
movement you know and uh I I think that
was excellent and and so nostalgic in it
of itself just having the hand-drawn
quality to it and uh I like them the
messages and and themes overall you know
it's
kind of a the similar type of message
that some of the live-action remakes of
like Mary Poppins returns or the the
sequel the Christopher Robin movie oh
this is our remakes like like remake
sequel thingies whatever the weird live
action films of of uh not getting so
caught up in a rat race and there's more
to life than monetary gain and trying to
make money uh that really you should
learn to be uh value and appreciate the
things in life that that you truly you
know
I truly matter the connections the love
the memories that you generate over time
those things like I love how they broke
it down from
you know there are things that you want
and then there are things that you need
isn't there a song like that you can't
always get what you want but you get
what you need is that how the song goes
um and so I really love that message
overall because that is any message like
that I always think of you know being
grateful for what you have in life and
realizing that's the little things in
life that are the most important is a is
a constant daily reminder you know like
I didn't grow up with money and you know
constantly just working many hours and
like many of the people I know many of
the friends that I have it it's and
especially being out in La you know I
don't know it's like in New Orleans it
seems like it's kind of around the world
it's a societal thing like the the
emphasis on the hustle the emphasis on
making money and how that seems to
equate to some type of value of a human
being
I I can I think so many of us can can
relate to that
of we often get blinded by the chase of
the external goals in life
and while I think like no there is like
there's an importance to that like she
ends up getting her the Tiana's Palace
in the end for a reason it's not like
she goes I don't need this you know I
just want love
the thing is in pursuit of that of of of
achieving that goal you you don't want
to lose sight of the things that really
do matter which are the experiences and
connections with the people we we love
you know I I do imagine of the the that
that feeling of if I'm when I'm on my
deathbed am I going to be thinking about
you know the getting those views of on
the channel and oh and those views were
great or
um you know the the the the money
successes I've noticed like any time
I've I'm always like even even in this
line of work you know
sometimes I could put like a lot of time
and editing into a certain video and
then it could do really well
and like that could feel like the most
important thing in the world to me in
that time
but then once I achieve it or does
really well or sometimes even you know
get go trending or something
that
doesn't feel quite I'm always
appreciative I don't want that to
misconstrue it doesn't feel quite as
rewarding as you sort of fantasize it
will be you know
and it's kind of been like that for
almost every aspect of my life that ever
involves some type of career-based or
job-based type of thing you know uh and
it's it's so easy to like compare
yourself to others or look at what
others have and I I love I love being
reminded of that message and watching
sports especially through the through
the perspective of a woman yeah I feel
like we don't really get that that often
It's usually the the guy even those two
live-action Disney movies I mentioned
those are men who are dealing with that
obstacle in their life of not being
attentive to their families and but if
it's the man so I I and I I really
really liked how we got it from a
woman's perspective and I like the Tiana
character I really like the portrayal
and there was something that felt
refreshing about it studied in New
Orleans with the jazz songs and
and uh and just the plot of how it
unfolded like doing a little bit of a
fliparoo when they both become frogs and
there's also you know some messages
there uh that they don't overtly speak
at least unless I missed it but they
don't quite as overtly talk on it
maybe more with the uh Prince Naveen
character who is
a lost soul in the time as well
but the the concept of you know not not
everything's about looks as well you
know like she's even like I would never
kiss a frog so they really do find true
love internally for who they are uh uh
underneath the physicality who they are
as Souls which is quite beautiful as
well and I love the the songs too like
there are two in there that really stood
out to me
um I believe one has to be called almost
there one of the earlier songs and then
the one with hold on I got I did pull up
IMDb on here it was Keith David hell
yeah I got that right
oh [ __ ] that was Oprah
did not know Terence Howard that voice
was very familiar anyway that's getting
caught up now and just getting the names
down it what was the the lady in the in
the swamp uh Mama Odie played by
Jennifer Lewis
um yeah Mama Odie her uh her song number
was also really awesome and I love that
one too
yeah there were parts of the animation
that kind of reminded me of Hercules
that kind of remind me of
um even parts of like The Rescuers Down
Under
and Jungle Book so I I really thought
that was that was awesome
so yeah messages themes the everything
was just like really light-hearted fair
that I that I thought was really
enjoyable I wouldn't say I quite loved
the movie and I think that was because I
wasn't quite in love with the characters
like I didn't I liked them all I liked
everyone here like literally everyone I
I really liked if anyone I came close to
loving if it's Tiana
um
but I but yeah I wasn't as
hyper invested in in the characters as
as I would probably be your like usually
with these movies it doesn't even need
to be at all I mean it usually just
needs to be like just that one who I'm
just like really drawn to
uh but I don't know there was I'm not
sure what was quite missing for it
from me there's something within the
the writing itself that sort of like I
like I said I don't want it to to sound
like I don't like the movie because I
actually do it I didn't like it I would
just say it I don't like the movie but I
I just it wasn't quite as um yeah I
guess there was a missing piece of
something there that felt like there was
some type of Gravitas that doesn't need
to be like the deepest thing in the
world but there was a bit of an
emotional weight that wasn't just quite
clicking for me that I I did I sort of
craved a little bit more of
because you know the day it's like a
breezy lightheart Affair and the movie's
made for kids and I think it excels in
that area and I think it's a family
movie with a lot of great things on its
mind and also with the expressive
Exquisite animation
and uh it's still solid voice
performances I I I still give it like a
really solid recommendation but yeah you
know uh I I I think it's a
just think it's a
it's just a fun light cute movie
you can see that I know that John has
seen this movie before and uh he he says
one of his favorites and and uh my now
wife Olivia is she at the another time
filming this but after
she she really loves this movie too and
for me I'm I'm not sure there was
something there that just quite wasn't I
know because I don't I didn't want to
like sit back here and like over analyze
it so I'm trying to sort of figure out
in the moment of talking with you guys
of what was it about this movie that
just didn't quite make me fall in love
with it and I guess yeah there was just
something about the characters in and of
itself that
was
there were parts of it that it's not
even the word flat that's a problem
sometimes when you do these movie
reactions and you're talking off the
Flyers you got it sort of figured out in
the moment
yeah I guess I just felt like I needed
something that felt a a little bit of an
extra umph in the
because it because yeah you know what it
might be it's not so much the the it
like I think Tiana like individually is
a wonderful character
it's more of the way the relationships
and connections form over time like even
with them falling in love it was like oh
I guess they hit that beat
but the way they got there I didn't feel
like I was there with them on the on the
journey to falling in love like oh
they've fallen in love
but I I didn't uh
I didn't feel though the the the the the
the the transition to there that strong
and then the other characters were kind
of like two-dimensional they all had
they're all like fun quirky but I think
like what really needed to sing like
massively for me was the connection with
um Prince Naveen and and uh and um
my God sorry for saving and uh Tiana
like that was the part of it that I
thought really needed to
really hit for me and that part I didn't
quite fall even though I was happy for
them in the end and I really like the
adorableness of it
yeah I guess my review was me explaining
why I liked it and really enjoyed it a
lot but didn't quite reach the I love
its level which can sometimes when
you're on the internet sound like you
don't actually like the movie when that
is not the case and so I felt the need
to really try to explain my way there
but really the
the answer is I I just really liked it a
lot but I didn't quite I didn't I didn't
fall in love with it
that's that's just the bottom line I
don't I don't know why I feel like I had
to really try to explain it so much
um but yeah I still thought those songs
were great I think there's so still so
much to appreciate and and I am really
grateful that I gotta watch this movie
finally it's been on my list for like
this whole year so I'm glad I finally
got to watch it and
I feel like I'd still revisit a couple
like I watched Moana recently and I
found myself like listening to a couple
of the songs when I'm like at the gym
and I feel like I put on a couple of
these songs as well or even just watch
the videos themselves because of the
animation for that really really sing
loudly for me
but yeah guys Princess and the Frog is
it one of your favorites do you love the
hell out of it
leave your thoughts down below be sure
to subscribe click that Bell leave a
like and uh hey let's send this with a
mark Leach mark
I want you to know buddy
that if you were a frog
I would kiss you I'd make out with you
Mark I just lick you all over I get all
that mucus all over me
I would hope to God
that if you were a frog you would choose
me to be the one you want to be kissed
by because Mark I love you I think
you're an amazing guy I think you're a
talented dude and you are someone who
from the things you've told me about
the interactions that you have you sound
like you you're probably an effective
influential inspiring
person to a lot of people
who are very important in your life I
really mean that part I mean I'm sure I
mean the part too if if you were a frog
I guess you sure I mean that too but I
mean the other more sincere things the
serious things that we've talked about
I really wouldn't take for granted the
experiences you told me about and what
you actually do for a lot of the people
around you
you sound like someone who's very much
treasured and valued and I don't think
you give yourself enough credit for that
so please know that just from what I've
gone to know from about you that you
seem like a
insanely insanely just
influential individual you're the real
influence around her he's like a real
influential person
and one of positivity even darkest times
so thank you for being in our lives and
I hope 2023 after all the [ __ ] that you
got dealt with in 2022 I hope 2023 ends
up being a a much bigger rebound of a
year they often say in life you know
You're Going Through Hell keep going and
I believe one of the keys to Life's
experiences is to experience so
sometimes you got to experience some
real darkness in order to experience
some real joy and you've had some
Darkness to deal with this year so I
hope in 2023 you're able to just have a
very joyous time
love you buddy hope you're doing well